what can you say about the kind of
formal structure the kind of formal
Foundation you can build such a formal
structure on
about the kinds of things you would
start on in order to build this kind of
uh deep computable knowledge trees so
the question is sort of how do you how
do you think about computation and
there's there's a couple of points here
one is what computation intrinsically is
like and the other is what aspects of
computation we humans with our minds and
with the kinds of things we've learned
can sort of relate to in that
computational universe so if we start on
the kind of what can computation be like
it's something I've spent some big chunk
of my life studying is imagine that
you're you know we usually we write
programs where we kind of know what we
want the program to do and we carefully
write you know many lines of code and we
hope that the program does what we what
we intended it to do but the thing I've
been interested in is if you just look
at the kind of natural science of
programs so you just say I'm going to
make this program it's a really tiny
program maybe I even pick the pieces of
the program at random but it's really
tiny by really tiny I mean you know less
than a line of code type thing you say
what does this program do and you run it
and big discovery that I made in the
early 80s is that even extremely simple
programs when you run them can do really
complicated things it really surprised
me it took me several years to kind of
realize that that was a thing so to
speak but that that realization that
even very simple programs can do
incredibly complicated things that we
very much don't expect
that Discovery I mean I realized that
that's very much I think how nature
works that is nature has simple rules
but yet does all sorts of complicated
things that we might not expect you know
as a big thing of the last few years has
been understanding that that's how the
whole universe and physics works but
that's a a quite separate topic but so
there's this whole world of programs and
what they do and very rich sophisticated
things that these programs can do but
when we look at many of these programs
we look at them and say well that's kind
of I don't really know what that's doing
it's not a very human kind of thing
so on the one hand we have sort of
what's possible in the computational
universe on the other hand we have the
kinds of things that we humans think
about the kinds of things that are
developed in kind of our intellectual
history and that's uh and the Really the
challenge to sort of making things
computational is to connect what's
computationally possible out in the
computational universe with the things
that we humans sort of typically think
about with our minds now that's a
complicated kind of moving Target
because the things that we think about
change over time we've learned more
stuff we've invented mathematics we've
invented various kinds of ideas and
structures and so on so it's gradually
expanding we're kind of gradually
colonizing more and more of this kind of
intellectual space of possibilities but
the the real thing the real challenge is
how do you take what is computationally
possible how do you take how do you
encapsulate the kinds of things that we
think about in a way that kind of plugs
into what's computationally possible and
and actually the the uh the big sort of
idea there is this idea of kind of
symbolic programming symbolic
representations of things and so the the
question is when you look at sort of
everything in the world and you kind of
you know you take some visual scene or
something you're looking at and you say
well how do I turn that into something
that I can kind of stuff into my mind
you know there are lots of pixels in my
visual scene but the things that I
remembered from that visual scene are
you know there's a there's a chair in
this place it's a kind of a symbolic
representation of the visual scene there
are two chairs on a table or something
rather than there are all these pixels
arranged in all these detailed ways and
so the question then is how do you take
sort of all the all the things in the
world and make some kind of
representation that corresponds to the
types of ways that we think about things
and human language is is sort of one
form of representation that we have we
talk about chairs that's a word in human
language and so on how do we how do we
take but human language is is not in and
of itself something from that plugs in
very well to sort of computation it's
not something from which you can
immediately compute consequences and so
on and so you have to kind of find a way
to take sort of the the stuff we
understand from human language and make
it more precise and that's really this
story of of symbolic programming and you
know what what that turns into is
something which I didn't know at the
time it was going to work as well as it
has but back in the 1979 or so I was
trying to build my first big computer
system and trying to figure out you know
how should I represent computations at a
high level and I kind of invented this
idea of using kind of symbolic
Expressions you know structured as it's
kind of like a a function and a bunch of
arguments but that function doesn't
necessarily evaluate to anything it's
just a a thing that sits there
representing a structure and so building
up that structure and it's turned out
that structure has been extremely it's
it's a good match for the way that we
humans it seems to be a good match for
the way that we humans kind of
conceptualize higher level things and
it's been the last I don't know 45 years
or something it's served me remarkably
well